you
Oh
you
Edwin sir down Jane come on you miss all
the fun I've been looking at your papers
don't worry about me sir I'm ready to do
my bit for king and country what sits on
you faint forward and reverse when
you're told you'll do all right for me
grab those wood yep come and meet big
bass women are your dreams
and a new driver boys
don't don't sweat she does not like it
when you swear Finch debuts done this
before don't work before magic business
among us listen don't worry she'll look
after you yeah all right boys this is
the big one our orders have to punch
through the German line destroying
artillery positions as we go yes
after that will advance on the French
town of cannon Bray when I have been
assured that was white women and song so
you should enjoy that car the man is why
Jesus are we in safe hands on what boys
eyes remember boys who your jobs they
care of each other my best will take
care of you then lord have mercy on our
souls get through this together Ryan
Watts bus driver
furnish it fully mamones bird small
block every feather of that damn easy
there but pension can save your life
it's our only line of communication
good or bad word yes starting to get the
hang of it what you do back home doh a
car I was a chauffeur
I'll Scott this is far enough infantry
oh boy in the first whistle then we
follow heavens above you ever seen
anything like this I have I'm sorry to
say listen we're gonna cut down the guns
up by that windmill
you
thank you
see that tiny cat box don't get us stuck
in the mud like that i sprung try
moving a clear shot at all steel guns
go you know
come one of those guns lots
those machine guns are holding our lives
back
possession here
German guns
Oh
the heels
she's on the retreat I said oldham keep
them suppressed
Wow good job lots now we take the next
trench line
take down that machine gun
all here and clear area sure our boys
are trying to move away
Jax
but can't get good
the D still young
from the infantry
in slow bench was the matter and adviser
hold this position both of their meeting
Jays
hey focus boys
don't mess with the pigeon forge on
there's our only link back to
headquarters hey Chad are you need is
really nice my dream save the fun and
games when they are either company at
all
two dead
well that's real gun
boys are books gathered dunno school for
the sauce boss
into the fight
down
but I need you out there take a look
watch her low stretch and let's go on
and lender behind
he good
God
making out
can I move on I'm
took on a damn Jonah and Alfie she's
gone my bad let's go yourself together
get a stir that village tryna that
artillery's hold up there
sure
my ears are ringing yup
you're too close did I feel good
great your lads let's fight
don't on that
gundam go
Oh
we've done right now
stuff you got
watch out
doctor
gone
yes
that one
keep pushing
taking us
ha
auxiliary your head now we cut them all
double check comes in on us
shut them off
fuka planet
honey would not feel dumb
many German defenses
gums done much
fingers over
don't we confer skill approach 80 get
any traction pushing back Rachel person
you should come here traxxas up come
over come
you're gonna get us all killed
release the Cajun there's an author son
do you understand me top
Oh
Oh
all
Oh
listen to future hey come on
Oh shucks if I wish it it's
great great Walter
here comes boys
nice server which I lads
you have the look of the devil townsend